president buchelli thank you very much
for speaking to Sky News you are El
Salvador's youngest ever president the
country has dealt with decades of
poverty violence and corruption how do
you plan to turn things around well
forever actually yes the country has
dealt with that forever since the
country exists I think it's it's it's a
quite a challenge and we have we know it
is quite a challenge some people say
they're probably we dream too much
everything that we can change things
around and it's impossible because also
there is so poor and so small and in the
middle of Central America which is a
poor region and we're in the third world
so what can we do about that I mean it's
too much too many challenges too many
challenges there are too big that had
been there forever corruption poverty
exclusion violence we have been this has
been a violent country for almost half
of a century since there before the war
you had insurgent groups then he had the
civil war then after the civil war we
had the homicide rate spike and now
we're fighting the gangs so actually we
have in Europe they've been in violence
in poverty and exclusion the lack of
economic growth if you see if you go to
the countryside is in the worst so so
when you look at all of the problems
together it seems like an impossible
task
but when you look one by one every
problem and trying to find one solution
for one solution for every problem
things have to change so it's a lot of
work and have a plan I do it well first
we are trying we are the way we are
trying to changing the thing how things
were done before we are we have a
cabinet that's working 24/7 I don't let
them sleep i text them at 3:00 a.m. and
4:00 a.m. and 5:00 a.m.
sometimes the
they don't answer but the answer early
in the morning they have to work in
Saturdays and Sundays it's like I told
him it's not our first month we old him
yesterday we had a meeting with the
cabin and I said it's not our first
month we only have 59 months left so you
have the thing that way because we only
have 59 months left and and in 30 days
we will only have 58 months that so it's
actually not quite a lot of time but I
think it's enough to change the way
things have been done in the past and I
think it's enough time five years is
enough time to not only change the way
things were done but also put the
country in the right path and that in
the in in every sense economics
corruption security everything even
politics we will change the way politics
the products were done so so I think I
think well I wish I think and I'm I'm
quite sure it's all other we have a
bright future compared to what to what
we have right now it would be a lot
different if well hopefully will be a
lot different when we look at this
country in five years the deaths of
Oscar Martinez and his daughter valaria
caused shock around the world some
Democrats in the United States blamed
Donald Trump for their deaths do you
know I well I
III don't want to be apologetic about
the United States immigration policies
that's that's that's not that's not my
point the point is that which which
country did Oscar and malaria fled they
fled the United States they fled Mexico
did they fled why Ramallah Wanderers
they fled our countries it's our fault
but didn't provide the security that
they needed here we didn't provide a job
to the NAD here we didn't provide
economic prosperity probably probably in
their family they didn't have a house
running water probably didn't have a job
if the first car Billy had had here a
decent job decent paint job a house a
community says it's safe for here for
for him for his wife it was for his
daughter they would be alive here
working so they felt that fleeing the
country crossing three borders a desert
a river which they find the litter on
that for them they felt that was safer
than staying here
so the only way to end this type of
tragedies is to make our country a place
where anybody would say probably has no
know everybody will have a perfect life
but everybody would rather stay here
rather to risk their lives crossing
three borders a desert and crossing
rivers we saw that we also saw that
video of that man say what's the
salvadoran and then that failed the
Train the Beast that is called it this
train he felt that he tried again into
the Train he felt and the Train cross
and cut his two legs
I mean what does did this man in his in
his in his the plenty of his life he
goes tries to tries to get into a train
falls down the Train cut his legs I mean
why did why do our people risk so much
to go to the United States a country
which today is what they don't know the
language they don't have didn't have
documents they will be called illegals
they will be third class citizens and
still they take all those risks to get
there what type of country do we live in
that the people have this urgency to
flee and there is their lives in their
kids lives and this was a loving father
I mean you could see in the picture he
roughed up his daughters I mean it's not
that he didn't love his daughter and he
say oh I will resume I don't know
he was I'm if you can see in the picture
there was a loving that and and they'd
run because they drowned because they
fled because they tried to get to
another country which is not their
country but they try to get there
because they felt that there that even
there even the risk were all those risks
were better than staying here at in
their home so so we I mean whose fault
is that it's our fault and this of
course we there's other things that you
can you can fix and in in with the
borders there's there's people that that
kidnap migrants in Mexico they they they
they traffic with kids to show their
organs I mean this is but but why would
what would people take those risks and
we're not talking about one to a
thousand we're talking about millions
right now almost three million one-third
of our population lives abroad I mean
one third of our population has had fled
our country why I mean isn't something
wrong with us of course of course we
it's something wrong with us is
something wrong with our country we have
to fix it were they only we're the only
ones they can fix it of course you can
get some help from the international
community from whatever NGOs but it's
but we have to fix our country so and
and every day that we don't fix it more
people like invisible Oscars and
invisible bulerías are dying trying to
cross and trying to get to the United
States it takes years to turn things
around are you concerned that you're
going to see many more die in the coming
months no in my life I was well I was a
businessman and then I was a mayor and
then I was mayor of the capital
I was I was blessed that I have never I
never took a decision they would imply
people to die now
almost all decisions imply people dying
because and it's very it's very hard to
say I mean it to be to be in the
position where you have to take it do
you have to take a decision that if you
even if you take it the right way it
will imply people dying it's very hard
for example if you go to our hospitals
we let medicines like medical supplies
with like the doctors we like we like
we're lacking nurses and you would say
okay let's let's get a half a billion
dollars more in the budget and let's put
into our hospital so people will not die
there but then we will not have enough
money to build roads and bridges and
water supply and the electric supply so
the country will not grow and three
years from now we will not have money
for the medicine and for the hospitals
so then you take it if you make the
decision to increase the budget but not
so much so you can fix the problem that
could be the right decision but at the
same time you're deciding that people
would not have medicine and that so what
I'm trying to say is that it like like
you ask it takes so long to fix
something that in the process people
will suffer because you're not fixing it
immediately
and and you're you're picking winners or
losers and this is I mean it's not it
shouldn't be that way
but what option I mean you you have you
want to fix other things you have to fix
it as fat fix it as fast as you can but
it but in the meantime migrants will
still risk will still risk it will still
try to go to the United States and was
still some of them will still be
kidnapped and will some of them will
still be raped
some of them will still die and and what
do we do I mean how do we fix it as fast
as as we can and you can say no I'm
working a lot yeah fine but but the
people that are dying are you gonna give
their lives back are you gonna are you
gonna bring them back to life further
when they're family the families that
have lost this do remember these members
of their families what are you gonna say
to them I mean you're gonna say no don't
worry we're making the country better I
mean yeah but they are really lovely
loved ones so it's it will take it will
take time and in the meantime we'll
still gotta suffer because of all the
problems we have violence healthcare
education exclusion immigration lack of
jobs in there so what else can we do but
run and work and do as best as we can
and try to fix the problems as fast as
we can so so people would not suffer
people will not die and people will stay
here in their homes but not only because
we tell them or because the we told them
their risk of it they know the risks but
but but still for them it's even riskier
to stay here so we have to we have to we
have to deliver results fast and we have
to that's why that's why it I don't know
this 32 days for us I felt it has been
like a year and and and hopefully we
will be able to make every month a year
so we will have 59 months left but it
would look like 59 years because this
opportunity to fix our country I will
not have it again mmm only opportunity
life will get me to do that so probably
I think we're going to we're going to
change things around turn turn things
around and we'll do as best as we can
Donald Trump said that a wall would have
stopped and ultimately saved Oscar and
valaria what do you say - I mean you
know the nervousness has all the right
to do a while they want to means their
country they can do a wall or whatever
in Europe you have a Mediterranean Sea
as a wall and people flee Africa and
they try to go to Europe to find the
same things people that playing or sobs
are looking in the United States so even
if you build them in the Turanian ocean
people will still go people were still
rescued and travel and try to and swim
and and get into a boat or whatever and
try to try to find prosperity and try to
find decent living for their families so
yeah they can build a wall I mean it's
their country but they can build in fact
if they build a Mediterranean ocean they
still they will still have migrants
trying to get to the United States
because people will flee poverty people
will flee insecurity people hopefully
will flee wars so that's just a fact
look at Syria I mean I'm not a man I'm
no fan at all of the leader of Bashar
al-assad but but they had a war in Syria
and now even doctors and lawyers are
fleeing with their families so why would
it what do they flee it did they flee
because Europe doesn't have enough
borders or or did they have that they
don't have enough border patrols or no
they flee because they have a war in
Syria so you know some other we do we I
mean we have such such bad conditions
that people will flee to the United
States because they think that they will
find a better life in there so they will
risk everything and if they build the
wall migrants will build the tunnel or
they will go through the sea or they
will I don't know they they will go
through the to their sides of the wall
I mean a wall would not have stopped
anything probably a wall would cause
more deaths because it will be harder
and people would try to build a tunnel
then the tunnel will fall and some
people will die and in the town and the
tunnel I mean physical barriers like
that they didn't like the river
only cause more suffering and death the
only way to stop migration humanely is
to develop the places they are migrating
from it's Donald Trump's responsibility
now I mean he's the pressure in the
United States he has to look for the
United States interests so it's our
responsibility right
so does Donald Trump wobbles has saved
Oscar now probably would have probably
another physical barrier will will have
more people died in the in the Triad
across but it's his responsibility no I
don't think so it's it's it's it's not
the note responsibility to fix all
Salvador Honduras or what a mile or the
south or southeast met in Mexico it's
our responsibility to do it so if they
want to help find if they don't want to
help well it's still a responsibility
there were reports that Donald Trump
used an expletive to describe your
country that he said that El Salvador
was a yeah what do you think of that
well I remember when he said that and I
said I I immediately I was mayor San
Salvador and I reacted and said that's
them let's demonstrate him there were
not what he says because you know you
get politicians in this region here in
this country in my country including me
and every poll and I mean we we tend to
be very we tend to get
we have a lot of the discourse dignity
it's like oh they are saying bad things
about our country yeah what are we doing
to make it better
we're doing what to make it different
they say oh you know stop but there are
politicians are correct oh they're
saying they were corrupt what why don't
we stop corruption then so then nobody
will say that and if they say that
they're wrong I mean this this what are
we worried about somebody's saying that
we are a [ __ ] that they're not from
set or giving the reasons to someone I'm
not I mean I'm not I'm not apologizing
for Donald Trump's remarks but shouldn't
shouldn't we certainly shouldn't be
better if we build the country that's
not a [ __ ] and if someone wants to
say it is well he's wrong
but right now I will never call my home
like that but but our hospitals are
crumbling our infrastructure is
crumbling our young people or yet
joining the gangs because they don't
have a job because they don't have
opportunities because their families
have been torn apart the immigration our
our countryside was very prosperous 50
60 years ago right now there are no jobs
we were importing bananas they say they
were a banana republic and we we eat
like 130 million bananas a year and we
import a 100% of them so a banana
republic imports all of their bin it's
bananas so we're not a banana republic
but we should be I mean which we should
we grow in those 130 million bananas so
I mean fine there's people don't want
the one of pop buster and BB it's fine I
mean we have we have free speech thank
God so they can I mean they can Clare
they can blame
and be mad at their remarks but but I I
prefer to focus in building a country
and building a society that's that
people will not call it called us that
way and if they do they're wrong because
we are not like that but we have to I
mean we have to demonstrate it with
facts not only with this course I don't
know if you've seen the images released
by the American government today if the
detention centers where migrants from El
Salvador and other countries are being
held they showed overcrowding reports of
people not able to use the toilet while
manager said that it's a ticking time
bomb how concerned are you about your
people inside those detention centers
very I think that we have to we have to
come up with a solution fast
I spoke with secretary secretary of
homeland security yesterday and when I
said I mean we have to come up with
solutions fast because this can this can
become a humanitarian crisis it is
already humanitarian crisis but it can
become something my worst you don't want
that on your on your back and we don't
want that for our people this is our
people so we have to take care of them
and and let's let's figure out something
that we can take care of our people we
can take them all back but we can do we
have to if if the United States chooses
to send them all back but we have to
come up with a humanitarian solution
decent human beings and these are not
delinquents or or I mean this is people
looking for a better life this even kids
there's a lot of for kids women old
people people with disabilities I mean
this is I mean
yes yes it isn't human and have to come
up with a solution and and we were if we
need to be part I mean we have to be
part of the solution and we're ready to
be part of it but we have to come up
with a solution before we have another
humanitarian crisis bury him in the term
catastrophe this is not about right or
wrong
is there money where I would prefer him
not to cut the eight of course I prefer
I would prefer him of him raising the
aid but is there money I mean the US
taxpayer they don't they don't they know
how to they don't have to they're not
obligated to send money to us
I I remember talking to secretary Ross
Secretary of Commerce of the United
States when they some days after they
cut the eight and said well it's
unfortunate you can do that of course
but maybe we can trade it for some for
with her with a trade mission so if you
cut the aid it's one hundred and thirty
million dollars a year we maybe we can
get some investments coming from the
United States here could be private
could be could be pushed by the
government they have the over overseas
Private Investment Corporation and we
got a loan for a private company US
private company for investing here in
energy the of two hundred and fifty
million dollars and they pledged that
they will they will have 1 billion
dollar in loans for US companies that
wanted to invest you so I said to
secretary or us okay you wanna if you if
your government wants to cut the eight
that's bad that's bad for us but maybe
we can trade it for best investment so
if we if we can create more investment
here that's gonna be better than eight
because we can create jobs and it's more
sustainable to just getting free money
so is he right well I don't know it's is
there money for us it's a bad is bad
news they're bad news but maybe we can
trade it for some other things that are
better for a country like investment and
the programs that were functioning with
that aid they're still functioning out
of the other the ADA was cut for a
solder for the next years is like five
hundred and forty million dollars so
they say that at the end they said four
hundred they out of the other five
hundred and forty million dollars
they said the four hundred and thirty
million dollars that are already that
are already in that they're already
placed or allocated in projects they
will still run so there's only like 100
and something million dollars that has
been cut and they say and we're gonna
we're gonna we're going to hold that
till we'll see until we see that this
country's are making the right things to
stop immigration so probably at the end
we'll still get most of the a but
anyways is I mean we cannot be asking
for free money and still be and be mad
if they don't send it right so I would
rather I would rather have the United
States send more aid to this country so
it would be good for them because if we
fix the problems here
I remember when george w bush said we're
gonna take the war to the Middle East
that it doesn't come here I don't
approve of the war but but he had the
logic of taking the war over there so
they would had they wouldn't have the
war their homeland so one that one what
not applying the same logic to
immigration if they if they send
perspiration jobs here they want to have
the migrants in their doors so I think I
mean the u.s. the US taxpayer and the US
government are free to do with their
money whatever they want but if I was
advising the years ago and I was not
present on the first table there of
course because there will be conflict of
interest I would say we should send some
prosperity and jobs over there
so the migrants won't come here one of
the key challenges you face is a very
violent gang
in ms-13 Mara Salvatrucha I've seen
first hand gang members inside prisons
here in San Salvador and I've witnessed
the families of victims in the United
States as well can you reassure the
public here in the United States that
we're gonna see a reduction in the
brutal violence that we've seen recently
I'm sure we will
yes get the gang sister the games is a
very particular in phenomenon this this
is not only a criminal issue if you see
at gangs here it's some some say there
are 50,000 sub said there are 60,000
some say there's 70,000 of course we
don't have a census but studies claim
between 50,000 and 70,000 gang members
here which is more or less 1% of
population living in a subway so that
will be over a little less than 1% so
that would be very a very small
percentage of the population causing a
lot of trouble but if you look at all of
them none of them not even one out of
the 70,000 or 60,000 whatever the number
not even one of them comes from marriage
bridge family minimum one of them not
even middle class they are all poor
there are proportional of course yes the
problem is that the issue has evolved so
much into a criminal organization this
is a criminal organization it it is
started because of poverty we I wish I
could set up a clock back right when
these kids were I mean where there were
kids and they were 12 and we could do
something about it but right now we have
people that have raped dozens of women
that have killed 3 4 or 5 people that
are in jail right now and some of them
are on the streets and
yeah he became again I'm 100% sure 100%
I don't have one one decimal of a
percent of a table they became a gang
member because of the conditions of
exclusion and poverty they live in but
what can we do now
but capture him and put him in jail what
else can we do I mean when we talk do we
talk to him do we tell them okay look a
stop raping women or stop killing people
this is a very this this should have
been solving nineties when you started
it wasn't
they let they they just let it grow grow
these grew it grew
I remember politician said no this is
just this is just like like a fad like
something that's fashionable right now
in the nineties it would would erode
itself and now it's probably the main
problem we have because it's not only a
security problem it's also a problem for
growing our economy no people will not
want it to invest in the country this is
plagued by gangs or tourism we have the
best surfing beaches in the world the
one of the best surfing beaches in the
world but a lot of surfers will say no
well I'm not gonna go because you're a
player guys so at the end it's a vicious
cycle because then you have more young
people without a job because the economy
doesn't grow and then not all of them
but 1% of them they joined the gangs and
they caused all this trouble so so we
have to fix the problem the holistic way
we have to go go to and dispute young
people I'm trying to get the young the
the young people before the gangs to get
them and we have to get the kids before
the gangs get them and we have to go
into their communities to say no you
don't have to join the gang you can you
can have the scholarship or do this and
we provide jobs for the for for the
people living in communities trying to
provide the things that the gangs are
provided in a way for example gangs
provide security for them it's it's it's
I mean it's ironic but they go they go
to the places that they have created a
chaos and they say ok do you want your
family to be safe yes ok so join the
kind so they provide they create
insecurity but the same time they
provide the security
if they join the gang but if the
government is able to provide security
then you don't have to join the gang to
be safe if the government is able to
provide you with a good education with a
job if the government respects you the
way you are if you like if you're not a
graffiti artist or you like breakdance
or hip-hop before that was considered
being like a gang like a gang like
behavior if you skate or if you have the
tools that's like being so and and a lot
of people were stigmatized by that but
but of course graffiti is an art also
it's in the world world recognized
worldwide recognized art tattoos are
Elson art body art so you have the skate
is a worldwide sport you have
international famous international
competition so rich what we would have
try to do is having ok with the
government with we have you can have we
have skate competitions you have
graffiti artists coming from New York
from Australia from Mexico from Europe
and now working together with graffiti
artists here and we make huge murals but
no but not with gang gang paintings but
we have a Martin Luther King with with
one of his sayings or something and then
so then then international media reports
that we did that when I was mayor since
table and we were all this graffiti
artists were subtly recognized and then
for them is for a 18 year old which is
easily swayed one way or the other
having the government not only the
national government but also
municipalities or even NGOs if if you
can provide the the good way like the
good path but but the good path is not
only the path of
a strong discipline and traditional
education but also deejaying or surfing
or skating or freestyling or break that
become we have more resources as the guy
who did the gangs we have more didn't
see we can get more coverage from media
we can I mean for yeah we can be on a
realtor alternative for young people and
that 1% can be reduced to 0.1% if you
reduce it to because all yoga's here you
also have psychopaths right but you can
then it will not be 70,000 Psychopaths
probably you have set 5000 Psychopaths
so then it will not be a social problem
or a poverty problem it will be a
criminal problem if you could provide
all the opportunities to him as he still
choose to kill people while he's a
criminal he's no sociopath we what he
will catch him and we'll take him take
him to jail the problem will be smaller
and even even in the worst case scenario
when the government is totally
incompetent and can get any of them
there will be still still be 1/10 of
what they are right now
so the crimes will be 1/10 of what they
are right now homicides would be 1/10 of
what they are right now and of course
the government shouldn't be incompetent
and should be able to get them and put
them to jail so I really think that we
could reduce gang violence and all
violence since Gangrel this year is 75
percent of all the violence so we can
reduce all violence gang violence
included and every other thing will
making a dent
even with 32 days in government but I'm
sure than one year from now in two years
from now neither has to say five years
from now there were the results and the
numbers will be very very different
does that mean more military and more
police on the street because some people
you speak to say that there's a culture
of fear around that yes
I don't you would have you should you
should do a like a not a poll but I'd
like a you know ask people on the street
I mean in London for example I've see
I've police officers sometimes they
don't carry a gun they don't need that
if you have a policeman without a gun
here he will be they will kill him
because it's a trophy for a gangsta
killa police the police officer so yes
we that's there's the same evil as the
gangs and we are fighting there today
yesterday we jail three police officers
but we captured three police officers
because they're suspects were being part
of extrajudicial killing group we'd
capture them and put them in jail just
yesterday no I mean killing is killing
if it's done by a gang or by this so
called what did they call themselves
they called well the extrajudicial
killing groups I remember how they call
themselves calling is murderous murder
so we will get anybody that commits a
crime if it's a gang member or a police
officer or government official or
whomever I mean he could be pressed a
priest or I don't if he commits a crime
and we know he has committed a crime
they will get him and will put him in
jail but what you ask about the presence
of military and police officers I think
it
I remember when when when some people
tourists come and they see in cafes
shops and or restaurants and they see a
guy with a gun shot with a with a
shotgun and they say what's happening
here so now it's just a guy who takes
care of the rest it takes security of
care of the security of the restaurant
said really but it's this place it play
safe yes I mean for us that's that
business as usual so for the population
seeing military are seeing police
officers in the street that that gives
them that that gives him a sense of
security shouldn't be that way but we
have to transition from violent society
to a peaceful society and we have to
control the territory have to have
presence of police officers and since we
don't have enough we recover it with
military so people will feel safe
walking in the street or will feel safe
selling or going to the right and to a
restaurant knowing that well at least
you can see police officers around so
you will feel safe at least safer than
the day before
of course you can feel safe and it kind
of feel safe and feel a lot safer in the
country that you need that but here you
do think that if you don't have that you
will have killings you're something
homicides will have people being
assaulted
so people are even asking to put one
police per bus we don't have enough but
people ask us to do that because they
feel safer if a policeman is in the bus
it's an incredibly divisive time in the
immigration debate and you have an
American president who's been accused of
being a racist do you think he is no I
don't think it's a racist no I don't
know I don't know him but I don't think
it's racist wouldn't make sense in this
light I mean I don't know his life but
I've seen it in TV and before he was I
think no of course I think that place
more to his base yeah it's probably more
an electoral discourse than really being
a racist I really don't I mean I'm not
judging him I wouldn't put my friends in
Miami in the fire for him either I don't
think it's racist I mean you have to and
for us the United States is just it's
not a mean it's not a thing you can
ignore I mean
totally the majority for exports go to
the United States the majority for
imports come to the United States we our
currency is the US dollar ninety percent
of our immigrants go to the United
States one third of our population
one-fourth of our population lives in
the United States and our economy is
tubes of this sub stained by five point
four billion dollars coming reminiscence
from the United States so for us the
United States is not a question as if we
were are we willing to work with the
another state I mean we have to work
with the United States we were in were
dependent there's so many issues within
either say that we just have to work
with them and try to find solutions to
the problems that we have that can be
solved working with the United States
and some of our problems are coming like
the immigration crisis in the border
that's it that's that is a problem
that's a common problem that we have
they have a problem and we have the
problem because it's our people and they
have the problem because they are in
their territory and in their custody no
no nor the US administration now they
have reached to us two to four the
immigration crisis for the people that
are in the United States we have issues
like TPS daca we have all sort of issues
trade aid investment political
geopolitical issues etc but no no
nothing nothing about Oscar about the
first thing I thought first thing right
so what's the difference between Oscar
in Bavaria and my daughter the first
thing with her the other day well the
difference is that he wasn't he our
country didn't provide opportunities for
him to to provide for his family so he
was trying to find that and
United States and he died in there in
the way yes yes of course
yeah and and knowing that Oscar and
Bavaria is just the face the tip of the
iceberg iceberg imagine how many Oscar
circle area we don't know about I mean
kids kids that bin not only dying in the
road they also have been killed being
kidnaps they sell their organs they
traffic with them with little girls for
sexual trafficking I mean knowing that
sometimes putting a putting a face to
tragedy makes us makes us put more
attention to the tragedy if you just
read numbers a thousand people die it
doesn't resonate it doesn't connect like
putting a face to it so knowing the
Oscar and buleria and their tragedy is
the face of thousands of Salvadorans and
no longer Salvador's migrants but in our
case Salvadorans then that suffer trying
to just because they're trying to get to
the United States fleeing our country
yes of course it's it's not that type of
aspiration you want of course but yes it
it if that doesn't move you I mean what
what will movie of course it's a it it
pressures us to do things faster and
better and and to commit not only to the
people but to ourselves that we cannot I
mean we cannot mess up I do we cannot
miss this opportunity up we have to take
advantage of this opportunity and fix
the problems that our country have we
have just fifty nine months left and we
have to and we have to fix it
president buchelli thank you very much
for speaking with us
thank you for